[Music]
[Music]
president thanks for being with us we're
here in the citizens garden next to the
european parliament in brussels it's
been six months since you took office so
it's time to take a look back what would
you say were the highlights of this
first semester for you well first of all
thank you
it is truly a beautiful place and a
beautiful morning to be here on
in the citizens garden it's been
let's say a very challenging six months
i would start
with the sense of responsibility that
i felt
after having been passed on such a great
legacy by my dearly missed predecessor
david sassoli a few days after he passed
it was that sense that i said i need to
take his legacy and bring it forward and
continue the great work he had done
already during a very difficult period
during the pandemic
and then looking forward to a high
legislative heavy agenda with big laws
that we need to debate and adopt and
push for the citizens but what i didn't
know at the time was that there would be
war in europe
so what
happened on the 24th of february with
russia brutally invading ukraine
leading up to the resilience and the
strength that we have seen of ukrainian
citizens and the help that they needed
from the rest of europe in order to
fight our fight in europe uh to
a decision that was taken a momentous
historic unprecedented decision that was
taken to admit ukraine and moldova's
candidate countries to the european
union i would say that those were the
highlights but also
the moments when europe and european
parliament was asked to deliver and i
think we did
yes candidate country status is some was
something that the european parliament
was pushing for
and uh but we all know that there is
still a long way for those countries to
become members of the european union how
can parliament further help those
countries in this road to the eu
well first of all we
made it clear already on the 1st of
march and that means a few days after
the russian invasion into ukraine that
we wanted ukraine
uh to be a candidate country uh to
accede to the european union in other
words to be to come on the path with its
european perspective why did we do that
because for me and for this parliament
when countries and its people look at
europe as their home then europe should
open the doors to them europe should not
close the door the pre-accession period
as we call it from when you become
declared a candidate country to
membership is a part that requires a lot
of work on both sides in other words
there are laws to be brought in line but
there are also programs to exceed
further integration we look at where we
are with trade with digital with
education research infrastructure all of
this
while ukraine is still fighting a war it
is a special situation but one where the
european union has stepped up and
definitely the european parliament will
continue to step up to play its part and
you just mentioned right now that
ukrainians were fighting our fight what
do you mean by that
you know the european union is not just
an economically interdependent bloc it's
not just member states countries that
trade with each other that do business
so to speak with each other it is a
group of countries that believe in the
same fundamentals when we talk about
justice when we talk about freedom when
we talk about peace and democracy these
are not just buzzwords we hold
each other and ourselves to account we
also make sure that those fundamental
values are defended across the world and
what we are seeing today is that ukraine
is fighting precisely for those
fundamental values i come from a country
that joined the european union in 2004.
in 2024 it will be 20 years it has been
a transformational process i know how
important it is to young people in those
countries to know that there is
protection there is security there is an
understanding that europe is a project
for peace there's also an understanding
that europe is one that brings your
quality of life higher that your
standards grow that your re your
opportunities to study to work to live
also grow i think that
is exactly what the ukrainians are
fighting for and that is what we should
help them to fight for and you think
that they being part of the european
union will help them on that fight well
when i met president zelinski on the
first of april in kiev he told me 97 of
ukrainians would like to join the
european union my answer was we will be
with you every step of the way that is
exactly what we need to do it is up to
us to make sure that that continues that
war fatigue doesn't set in that we don't
give the impression that one country one
autocrat can threaten the territorial
sovereignty the integrity of other
countries on our continent that is not
acceptable what is happening on our
continent today are war crimes and we
need to push back against that and fight
against it and that's what we will do
and we have seen in the latest syrian
barometer survey that most of europeans
support the european union's response to
russia's aggression against ukraine we
have also seen that support for eu
european union among europeans is higher
than ever how do you interpret this
increase on support in this precise
moment
it is the support for the european union
also the support for the european
parliament and i would think that there
has been a tectonic shift
uh in
in europe as to how citizens look
to europe and its institutions and its
leaders to act we saw it already during
the pandemic
when the first instinct was to close
borders
after that we open up why because we
needed each other for medical equipment
for movement of of medical professionals
and most importantly for vaccines to be
made available for all eu citizens and
then with the highest ever economic
recovery package that is needed to steal
today for all those citizens and people
living in europe who need that help
because of what they have suffered
during the pandemic what was the message
from all that europe matters today
during war europe matters as well and
what we have seen across all parliament
in europe that citizens have asked their
representatives to go further do you
think that the crisis all of this latest
crises
have shown europeans the benefits of
being part of the eu i think they have
shown europeans that if there was no
europe then the situation would be worse
that europe matters and europe can be
more and this is why we are having the
conversation how can we go further let's
look at the next few months it's going
to be very difficult we are facing an
impending food crisis we are facing
energy cuts we are facing the the
understanding that we are not
interdependent enough when it comes to
energy sources some countries are
further ahead on renewables than others
some countries have had to fire up uh
coal plants that they have not had to do
that for decades so the decisions that
we will take over the next six months
will also require
big responsibility sometimes with
difficulty at the european level which
need explanation which need cushioning
because at the end of the day we need to
explain to our citizens why decisions
are being taken but once we do that and
once we understand that there is no
other way to do this than together
in europe then i think we can manage it
will be difficult but we will have no
other choice we are saying that some
countries are already reopening some
coal plants to make sure that they don't
fall into shortage of energy in the
coming winter
what do you think about this decision
was there any other option for them
this was already something that started
to happen last autumn when prices of gas
and electricity started to go up
we were facing in fact quite a lot of
misinformation campaigns already then
blaming the green deal climate
legislation at the end of the day this
was a market situation that drove the
prices up this is a concern that all
governments and the european parliament
has in some cases because there have
been gas cuts because there are no
alternatives unfortunately coal plants
have had to be fired up again what has
to be our ultimate
goal zero dependence on russia for gas
for oil and for coal at the moment we
are still far away from that that is why
the sanctions packages were so important
the bans were so important we need to go
further but at the same time we also
need to see where are we on investing in
renewables where are we on making sure
there are not so many energy islands in
the eu where countries have more supply
but they can't they can't transfer it to
anywhere else at the end of the day what
we also need to say is where do we buy
and we're talking about common
purchasing we're trying
we're talking about pooling of resources
where do we buy or depend on our energy
from on our foes or on our friends i
think we need to certainly talk about um
an energy union that seriously addresses
all the citizens in the eu i also wanted
to talk to you about the conference on
the future of europe it's something that
marked your first semester european
union has brought together citizens from
all countries different profiles
to discuss about the future and put for
their ideas to improve europe
how important was this for democracy in
europe
i think one of the the best moments over
the past six months was the 9th of may
day of europe in strasbourg
where we go where's our seat as a
european parliament and we we travel
there for our plenary every month on the
9th of may thousands of young people
were in that room and said the european
union needs to evolve it needs to adapt
it needs to change there are gaps that
need to be filled we want more
i was there together with the president
of the european commission and the
president of france holding the rotating
presidency and promised
to return those demands with proper
proposals on the table this is the
parliament's position and this is the
one that i will push for and then you
ask the european commission to put
forward proposals to respond to the
recommendations that the citizens put
forward during the conference which kind
of proposes do you want to see well i'm
definitely looking forward first of all
to the state of the union but also to
the decision by the european council to
trigger the convention that the european
parliament has asked for a decision that
has to be taken by simple majority uh it
is a a demand a request that we will
continue to push for
i think that we have seen that in health
there is definitely more space for
european union to act together we have
also seen now in energy that there is
more space for the european union to act
together there are discussions going on
as to what kind of of how decisions they
are taken which what kind of of of
voting procedure for example but i would
also
think that we need to have a
conversation so what it is do the
citizens want from us it's not high
rhetoric not big words not numbers
in documents they want us to deliver on
real tangible deliverables and i think
that there if we have seen what they
want from us today whether we act on
migration on energy on health on digital
i think there we can look at our
infrastructure our treaties what can we
change there and let's have the
conversation about that and since we're
talking about the way forward
um in the next semester what do you see
as the most important topic what should
we keep an eye on well first of all we
need to continue to make sure and help
ukraine to win the war
that is our overarching goal peace in
europe we cannot look away from that
because that is precisely what russia
wants from a legislative perspective we
have a huge work ahead of us we have all
the trial logs in other words the
discussions that will take place in
negotiations between the european
parliament and the council on all the
climate packages we need to see where we
are moving on migration package we're
going to focus now during the czech
presidency on resilience we need to be
prepared on how resilient we are for
possible future pandemics we need to
make sure that we are better equipped
from a digital point of view we need to
fight more against disinformation
misinformation we are entering
ultimately what is
the period that is preceding the
campaign right all members of the
european parliament 705 of them are
going to go back to their countries and
say we have delivered on this we need to
do more on this believe in europe and
vote in the european parliament that
will be leading up over the next couple
of years and that is something that i
have not only the privilege but a big
responsibility to to together with my
colleagues in order to deliver on and
that's going to dominate our work that's
a full agenda for next semester that's
all right i'm used to it but before that
we still have some weeks of summer to
enjoy what should we be reading during
the summer oh i like to read food books
and political biographies so
i just finished the second book by by
ben rhodes who was this the spokesperson
for for barack obama but i also have a
penchant for for stanley tucci and i'm
reading his book uh called taste
the art of good food i can't get the
title now and i absolutely love to do
that and i love to cook so i will be
spending a lot of time in the kitchen
that would be good and do you have a
soundtrack for that
summer soundtrack
whatever comes up on any of my playlists
unless my kids are listening to my
account at the same time and then i have
to listen to their
terrible taste and music if i say that
well we'll conclude this interview here
here from the citizens garden next to
the european parliament in brussels i'm
marce bisotto and this is roberto
mitzola president of the european
parliament thank you thank you